good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Tuesday it is
bright and shiny in New York and in our
hearts as well because we just premiered
our groundbreaking historic interview
with dr. deborah birx a doctor on the
White House Task Force for coronavirus
she's an amazing inspiring woman we got
you so amazing she was so wonderful and
beautiful so lovely so informed so smart
and you know what the most important
socom like in this time of panic I feel
like it's so important to have leaders
who are just being calm and you're not
making you pad and then still in calm in
other people and you actually got to
Skype with her and before we started the
interview we like had like a
three-minute chat yeah and it was just
like a couple girlies talking about life
you know loved our scarves if you
haven't watched it yet head over to our
YouTube channel after the show and watch
the interview did a pre-recorded YouTube
premiere which was an inspired decision
by you thank you well we've never done a
satellite interview before because we've
never deemed anyone important enough to
like make that work nobody has and it
worked I love when technology works in
our favor no no it never works in our
favor and I was 100% sure that between
like the Skype us then like there would
be some sort of one hiccup and there was
one small hiccup before we started with
my stupid [ __ ] air pods but besides
that of course White House technology is
fabulous and it was so fabulous what's
so funny Zac always makes fun of me for
the way that I wear my ear pods because
I wear them out okay get up down the
only thing I looked at during the
interview was your [ __ ] air pod
angling out of your year he was watching
it this morning before I left and he was
like your [ __ ] air pocket I was like
why can I not see mine but hers and I
was like maybe my hair is covering mine
but no yours was literally sticking out
like an alien antenna yeah I just wear
them weird and then I never know what I
look like wearing them because I'm just
like not wearing them a friend right
here and so it's the first time that I
realized like oh damn I do look pretty
stupid with the way that I wear them
okay well it doesn't mean you're usually
not on camera while wearing yeah but
also like it was just like I had a
little thing in my ear it was an iconic
moment and really a very informative
interview I feel like I learned a lot
more and Ben was asking me so many
questions as always about coronavirus
and he actually had proof I'm like well
dr. Burke said this oh right if you
watch the interview I think you guys
will really like it you know we have a
little bit of fun but for the most part
it was very serious and really helpful
we got we tried to get as many of your
questions from Instagram to the doctor
because we were just telling her like
everyone needs help they need
guidance there's so much misinformation
being spread and you're the only person
with real answers so what's gonna rattle
off questions dr. Burks is that okay and
she said yeah she said yeah and it was
it was so fabulous like a couple of
fabulous queens just chatting do you
know how relieved I am it's that it's
over yes because I feel the same
we had been reached out to by the White
House Task Force on Thursday so we had
been oh maybe Wednesday actually so we
had been you know try to figure this out
this was before you know Governor Cuomo
put the mandatory like rules in place of
having to stay home so we had another
studio set up that could Skype for us
and then we had to do it ourselves we
were freaking out and then you know her
schedule is so crazy she had to change
the time I'm sterilized gum rinses here
there and we were just like bobbing I'm
so glad it's over and I'm so glad that
it went well I'm so let me have that
under our belts and I'm really glad that
the toasters now can hear from
professional from a medical expert who
is in dr. Theodore for Chapman yeah
because you know he's a little biased
and actually breaking news dr. Theodore
for Chapman has fallen ill and I'm like
devastated about it any and I need to
run home after the show like he threw up
in the middle of the night and if you've
ever heard a dog throw up they make
these horrible sounds before it
literally sounds like a submarine like
underwater and it was so sad obviously I
think it had a bad been dead and because
he was always doing weird things in the
millon it-- and then he got up this
morning and usually if one of us moves
at 7:00 a.m. feels like I'm ready for
breakfast I'm ready for the day and he's
saying you're facing nine o'clock he was
still sleeping and that's that's a bad
sign like when a dog is feeling
lethargic so I spoken to feels bad dr.
Lisa literally a text her all the time
she wants to kill me she said he's not
she's not super worried he might just
like you know he might have eaten
something weird if he throws up again if
you can't keep down his breakfast from
this morning I'll keep everyone updated
because I know you're just like waiting
with bated breath the doctor needs a
doctor yeah or do you think maybe it
made him so sick to his stomach that we
got a second opinion have you watched
curb yet I did so now do you get it yes
I was shook that when and you um told me
about the episode you didn't mention the
incredible appearance by Chaz Bono
I try not to spoil anything so I was
watching it I'm like who is that and I
couldn't figure out who the character
was because there's so much weird stuff
going on with the funkhouser families
they're just throwing in funkhouser's
left Andrew Barney Funkhouser died and
they didn't address it and then Mindy
butts the same Vince Vaughn comes in as
like an other fundraiser yeah yeah and
then the daughter a transition and we
met the daughter after she transitioned
so I'm just so confused by the
funkhouser's and I'm like who is this
person and then I realized it was Chaz
Bono and then I realized it was Joey
funkhauser how good of an episode was it
it was really good it was making me sad
I feel like it definitely is not the
series ending it is I just saw it on
Hollywood Reporter
yeah and they think it was like an
ominous like nod to the pandemic maybe
because the Purell bottles like were a
flammable source no but it definitely
was like a really brilliant like comedic
full circle moment like everything came
back with the Purell the table's bolted
the toilet it's like it all came down
and also mojo yep and the assistants
fight house yeah
but my favorite part was like the the
Today Show clip of like all these
celebrities now starting to make their
own spite stories and when he went to
the jeweler l.k went out of business and
there was m'kay and it was Mila Kunis it
was so funny it was so funny Wow I'm
just like still upset about dr. Foreman
or his presence has really been missed
on the show moon you think maybe he's
sick because he's just like getting
cabin fever maybe he needs to like
switch it up and spend time at his
auntie's no I don't think that's it at
all I think he's very happy where he is
no y NT has a peloton Jackie got her
pills gosh she's so annoying I can't
believe I got a Palitana I dreamed up
this idea on Friday that if I had a
peloton like maybe I wouldn't become
like just a large lazy oath during
quarantine and then I was able to get an
earlier delivery time I guess someone
cancelled thank you to that person so
much like you've made my dreams come
true at the grand prospect hall and my
peloton was delivered yesterday they do
a really good job of like making it very
sanitary right um they're very on top of
it and they are still delivering right
on top and I got my peloton and then I
got on my peloton to do a class was the
seat comfortable it's yeah the seat was
coming I mean it's comfortable as a spin
bike gal but the bike is kind of
different than SoulCycle and it really
was an adjustment and like trying to
like create the vibe of still cycle like
in my house was kind of weird you need
to get like a smoked fog machine and
like mirror yes because like when I was
dreaming of peloton I was like I'm gonna
have musical Monday in my house anytime
I want it you need also they should sell
peloton's with VR glasses so like you
could look like you're in a studio
sure but there is a huge monitor yeah
and the instructor is in a studio so
like it's studio guides but I I don't
doing two classes the first one was okay
but I just like my music wasn't loud
enough my speaker was over there and I
couldn't get off the bikes it took me
too long to clip in or the classes live
or you could join pre-recorded ones both
so the classes are liveing a lot of
people do live classes because it's a
community and there's like a leader
board right and you begin there faster
than those classes much like the are
duties that's what they're up for ever
so I did a 30-minute class that was
pretty good and then I was like I could
do a little more so I went up doing the
20-minute country ride it was fun with
an instructor named Ally love and I
really liked it
so I loved it I Ally loved it so I think
I'm getting I'm getting better I'm gonna
get more comfortable but my back
afterwards broken broken life yeah a
couple of Brokeback queens no you don't
even understand I got a prescription for
muscle relaxers ever it was like insane
yeah from a toaster no no from a real
doctor yeah cuz when they put out the
appia nobody helped but so I went the
the main way and I got muscle relaxers
and I took it she was like you just take
it before bed I was told drive like a
real sensitivity to drugs and she's like
it'll make you fall right asleep I
called Olivia who's taking muscle
relaxers before she's like yeah it'll
just pass right out told me nervous cuz
I'm very nervous about taking drugs so
eight thirty on the top get in bed take
my little muscle relaxer literally they
did not go to bed till 12:30
nothing happened Olivia's like you're
gonna wake up like kind of fuzzy like
you've never gonna sleep like that in
your life literally stop terrible and
didn't feel a thing go to bed till 12:30
maybe that's because it was really
working on your muscles like sometimes
when you take a sari and my back hurt
more than ever oh okay literally woke up
and sat down to pee and started
hysterically crying and been out to come
pick me up off the toilet yeah yeah
we're really getting into like the weeds
of our marriage oh for sure it's
whittling down to like you need to wipe
my ass soon oh for sure but I would do
for bed bed like whenever like if I'm
the second I was like been like in
glitter it needs to give me a shower
he's like oh my god where's like if you
were sick I would literally blow
medicine up your ass okay [ __ ] off
it depends well the other great show for
you guys today and you didn't catch our
deborah birx interview go check it out
after this episode and if you're a
podcast listener the audio from the
interview will be clipped at the end of
the show but I think watching it on
cinema is really the best experience
it's usually like I try and you know shy
people away from the live stream
I was like oh maybe I don't know we had
some tech problems but this is as
premium as it [ __ ] gets you guys
today is also pretty premium yeah well
the Sun is out the Sun is out you're
literally looking like you popped out of
heaven and I'm looking like Satan in all
black but I feel as though that's
reflective of our dynamic oh for sure
but also this set has inspired me to be
more cleany because it's just like it's
yeah or my outfit is day court for the
show yeah when you've a broken back you
can only put on so many pieces of
clothing and leggings in a sweater is as
good as it's gonna get you would be
surprised at how comfortable these
trousers are listen you and your
hula-hoop you gotta find up in a pair of
trousers sweats there sweats okay or you
could also just wear sweats
you could you could if you're just
trying to switch it up on a beautiful
day in New York that we don't get to
experience the type of day where I'm
like damn I wish I was drinking a glass
of scotch a day alfresco fanchetti
alfresco but you got a last I'm not I'm
eating a [ __ ] fruit by the foot in my
bed for the third day in a row but the
more that we self-quarantine the sooner
we will be drinking sunchat alfresco and
that's what deborah birx really drove
home for me she definitely loves the
shots on Cherry alfresco did you see
what our husbands are doing last night
uh I didn't because I was locked away in
my room with my back and a heating pad
but I heard something to the effect that
they were playing a game over the phone
so me and Ben and our group of friends
have a scheduled scattegories game over
zum at 8:30 and it's hard to play game
over zoom but scattegories has made me
like the only game you could play and it
was so fun and Benton to play because he
had another conference scheduled via
zoom of a virtual game of Monopoly and
they literally created this like Google
Doc Monopoly board they're getting heard
they said they're gonna patent it and
try and sell it like it was kind of
genius they were playing over a zoom
conference call but on the board on
Google Johnson on a spreadsheet red
sheet that they were all and it was
color-coded and Ben was rolling the dice
like there was a Google Doc for the dice
like it was this whole thing he was
playing for four hours literally was
crazy been doing it to bed until 1:00
I'm so glad that it worked out they have
this monopoly league that they started
during the quarantine before like people
were really taking it seriously like
three weeks ago and now they haven't
played in like over a week and they've
been dying to play so now they decided
to play virtually yeah I'm happy for
them know that I am I'm also happy for
the toasters were about to get hit with
something fabulous Oh
I think I'm happy for them to be
actually have some great stories um
as per usual oh we didn't um choose a
toast movie of the week oh we didn't but
let's do that at the end I have so many
thoughts on the one from yesterday I
loved it well I really loved it loved it
was the perfect sort of movie loved it
it was really enjoyable but we'll recap
okay without further ado I'm gonna
assume based on yep it's time for the
Fast Five story is that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast and if you're
anything like me your morning toast is
burn
crunch and that's true Jackie but you
know we have we have nothing but time so
I don't really want to like you know
speak on you know step on your toes
speak on your behalf but I feel as
though I have a duty and it's me you
it's brown I have a duty to tell the
toasters the most the truth you know I
have nothing to hide I am a transparent
woman I've I'm a woman of many words and
one of them has to be the today's
episode is brought to you by Yamaha
they've been focused on audio for over
130 years when it comes to working from
home nobody's better than Yamaha relying
on laptop audio can lead to a poor
experience audio up a poor audio
experience we can result in
misunderstandings frustration and even
stress or fatigue to keep your team's
functioning at a normal level while
working from home during this quarantine
we are here to let you know about one of
their portable speaker phones that
should be a no-brainer when you in your
work from home kit its discreet and
compact device that lets you throw it in
a bag take it anywhere but it's also
packed with technology to make you sound
great on conference calls blackout and
any unnecessary background noise it even
has an easy mute button if your dog is
barking
your husband's bothering you or sirens
are going off you can connect the
software to any software like zoom Skype
Microsoft teams you can listen to music
between meetings or even the morning
toast between calls give yourself and
your team the right tools to collaborate
and keep your business on track during
this quarantine and because Yamahas
teams are full of toasters we have an
iconic promo code for you if you want to
grab 10% off all their work from home
devices go to UC dama hakam slash toast
for more information again that's letter
U letter C dot Yamaha why am i aah comm
slash toast for more information Thank
You Yamaha for being today's sponsor yes
oh my god I love Yamaha it's really like
helping our work from home situation and
they make a mean keyboard too oh and
they make a mean keyboard and I just
found our toast movie of the day okay
okay are you ready for our first story
in some happy news yes Maren Morris
gives birth welcomes baby boy with her
husband Ryan heard I know it feels like
she's been pregnant forever but I feel
like the birth happened really quickly
because not wasn't yesterday she posted
a video on her story like of her belly
literally popping out and she said
eviction notice get out like I felt like
so long but then it just happened you
know I guess that's how pregnancy works
yeah it's a beautiful thing her son's
name is haze Andrew heard that's the
name haze ayes yeah as like Hunter Hayes
yeah Walker Hayes actually he was fired
by the haze Bros oh he's heard they're
obviously gearing him up to be a country
artist oh my god I mean he has to be no
pressure or anything
he's I love this I love Maren Morris I
love Ryan her they're the cutest couple
I love that she like got pregnant at the
absolute peak of her career well who
knows if it's the beak but it's a peek
and I just love that she gave birth
healthy and happy during the quarantine
I'm always so shocked when I'm realizing
that other things are happening oh you
know what and hospitals are being used
for other things other than treating
sick patients and this is like a
controversial topic I wanted to take
your pulse on because I saw a petition
going around that there's been a law
passed I'm not sure if it's just New
York or worldwide that in hospitals if
you're giving birth during the
quarantine you have to be completely
alone in the room with the doctors and
nurses not your husband not your family
and people are really upset about it and
there's a petition going around it has
like almost a million signatures of
pregnant moms or just anyone who's who's
upset about this new ruling and I'm all
for like power of the mom but I just
feel like that's being put in place to
ensure everyone's health so obviously it
stinks for sure but I don't think it's
wrong what do you think um I don't know
enough about I'm gonna find I don't
I saw the petition and I don't know the
law but I think giving birth is very
traumatic
you don't extreme and doing it alone is
so scary it's so scary I think you
should be able to bring one person with
you it's New York the Department of
Health issued clear guidelines on
treating patients in labor during the
kovat crisis these guidelines determined
a support person whether a spouse
partner or other chosen person is
essential to
for the patient during labor delivery
and the postpartum period but as of
March 24th they will all act against the
guidance and ban all support people
including spouses from labor and
delivery and postpartum units well
postpartum like come on go just one
person who has to be like below a
certain age yeah and maybe they have to
get even tests actually the tests take a
few days to come and they're so hard to
get yeah but they have to be suited and
booted but you can have one person like
below the age of 40 yeah then I guess
that person is also possibly infecting
if they are doctors and nurses that's
true
I just realized that coronavirus is so
aegis it's much like Shark Tank oh my
god like no wonder I just had like this
visceral reaction to it this you're so
right you've always been on the pulse of
ageism and like how it affects society
yeah and I'm always just like standing
with the elderly always and like the
boomers well you're like sitting with
the elderly but yes we are sitting
comfortably or we're standing leaning
against something so true yeah just this
maternity thing I was wondering like
what people thought about it because
obviously it sucks but I feel like it's
for the greater good right so I was just
interested about it because she's
obviously pregnant and has more of a
stake than I do but I'm not pregnant so
I can't really speak on it but I just
felt like it totally sucks but it if if
the hospitals are saying it like the
doctors are saying it must be the right
thing to do it just sucks yeah it just
sucks yeah but it's just New York
according to the petition I just resting
that is sad but it's crazy times like a
lot of things are sad right now yeah
it's just so crazy that like people like
it's just so weird to me that life is
going on outside of Kuran virus because
for me I'm obviously not pregnant to me
my whole life is current about it so
it's just weird that people are like
living their lives in other way it's
like people are becoming moms like Mara
Morris right we're becoming pregnant I
think a lot of people are gonna become
pregnant yeah well what else is there to
do ladies yeah but they don't become
pregnant like you can't really go to the
doctor right now oh that's true how do
you get an ultrasound but you don't need
an ultrasound until like a few weeks
down the line and hopefully hopefully
Hashem would be clear okay hopefully
okay dr. Brooks said you never know this
next story is a twofer that I'm looking
forward to hearing your opinion on
because I think you're gonna have strong
opinions I mean what else is new
hime is postponing their new album due
to coronavirus concerns however on the
other hand do a Lippa is pushing up her
album release due to coronavirus yeah I
mean to be honest like I've said it a
few weeks ago artists who are pushing
back the release of their albums when
the album's are like already ready
associated to me because the only reason
they would be doing it is because they
want to like have a moment have press
like they think it might affect album
sales and of course business is business
but these people are millionaires I'm
like I just think you look so vapid if
if you're doing it if you don't have any
other reason yeah because there's no
like there are certain things like
movies need to be postponed because they
really can't go see them but does that
like we're buying CDs at the store in
our so there's no reason to push back an
album and I'm by the way music and new
music is something that people could
really use right now except for like
monetary reasons yeah I'm curious if
people who have released music like I
know Kelsea Ballerini released her album
and people are releasing new songs I'm
curious if there's been a spike in
streams or people are not listening to
music I have to imagine that they are
yeah well Julia actually is pushing her
album up because it leaked online
oh okay so that makes sense but I think
people should push their albums up like
we need music right now totally like
literally if my [ __ ] comedy special
could come out tomorrow I would I would
do it yeah and I feel like certain
artists like we there's a if there's a
specific vibe of music I want to listen
to during coronavirus like like Kacey
Musgraves say coming low-key mellow but
if you're like pushing out like summer
jams
yeah I think julep it probably is yeah
it's like I don't want to bop around to
those in my house no but do Ali bill I
could put out a fart on a plane and
everyone would love it like anything she
sings like it's just gonna be a hit her
news no but it's also just so good it's
not what she sings it like her new stuff
has been so good she hasn't it out of
that song like ever really not know when
he might have just been overplayed but
like they are always good toys now like
jumpy cup phone and I use it as a song
you know it's obviously over plated in
annoying but it's literally one of the
best songs of our generation so I think
to Aleppo is fabulous I'm sorry that her
album got leaked that absolutely sucks I
really started to sympathize for artists
whose work gets leaked when I watch the
Lady Gaga documentary like she put her
entire life into Jo Ann and then lit her
like [ __ ] CD store and Denmark leaked
it online because they had gotten it to
put on the shelves like a week before so
it's really sad when that happens like
you put so much effort into it but back
to him I just want to really emphasize
how lame I think this is like you're
associated you're so shy steeped in the
words of amber from love is blind and I
just I don't like it like it's so
obvious it's so transparent like your
motives are not pure yeah thank you
reason just because of coronavirus due
to everything that's going on with kovin
19 and the changing nature of travel
policies and Quarantine 'aa cross the
world we decided it was best to postpone
the release of women in music part three
to later this summer um we can't rate to
who reschedule everything we had in mind
for you all I mean can't wait to see all
of you on the road when it's 100% safe
to do so so basically they had a whole
like dress travel tour shows in
different cities Global a whole thing
planned and they can't do that so they
want to wait until they can know and
this is not to say if I had an album
coming out that I wouldn't postpone it
because you know I'm a big hypocrite but
to me I just have a lot of respect for
the artists who are still just for
Kelsea Ballerini release and she's doing
the press that she can she released a
makeup tutorial on her IG TV because
that's all we can do right now like I
have respect for artists who are just
giving the people what they wanted like
fans wait a long time for new music and
I mean I'm not personally a Haim fan but
if I was I can imagine I would be very
disappointed so it just it sucks
already' he's released a few singles and
they said they're gonna be releasing
more singles um but now I'm just reading
this blurb that's very interesting the
band recently performed a five-date deli
tour did you hear about this across
America in honor of their first ever
show in 2000 which took place at
Canter's deli in LA their first stop on
the tour was Sarge's deli in New York on
March 10th where they covered Britney
Spears is I'm not a girl not yet a woman
everything about this story is so us yet
I didn't hear one morsel Evan Haim is so
weird because like I should be their
number one fan they're three sisters
they're three Jewish sisters they were
supposed to be called the bagel [ __ ]
they loved hellish but like I should
love them I literally
along the wire that song is so good you
know by the way they have a few gamers
you know hmm we are hanging baby yeah of
course with the big alleges I guess I
just I can't get into them they're so
like weird an alternative we saw them at
1989 concert they opened for Taylor
Swift and they were actually fabulous
they're really true musicians they're
not a singing group they're a band like
they play the drums they play the guitar
they're so fabulous no like rocker
chicks I just like um have never gotten
into them when I feel like I should be a
big fan of theirs they're little too
like you know grungy Brooklyn for me
yeah I agree like I totally agree but I
love that song I just need to find out
what since you're playing The Wire
remember it was huge even though yes no
by the way I know exactly what you're
talking about Amy it was so a Hamish
Haim and like for a while I thought it
was hyeme yeah why are you it are you
gonna listen to it okay we won't be able
to monetize today's episode but okay
anyway he's cool I'm sorry for the Haim
fans you're gonna have to wait I excited
further to do a lip of fans because this
is sickening
yeah myself included I really has
nothing to do with coronavirus it's just
so now I'm putting pitting women against
each other oh my god you're always
[ __ ] do I thought I had like an
interesting idea for her story where I
took two stories and I compared it I
thought they were in the same article
and instead I'm pitting women against
each other well I think Julie Benz is oh
sorry gonna go down in 10 years as like
one of the biggest Lady Gaga part - yeah
I always liked her music but I had a
newfound respect for her when I saw her
perform at the prime Day concert what
she liked was a part of like a set with
Taylor Swift and she is just a stellar
singer dancer performance this vibe like
this ambiance on stage a real presence
she connects with the audience she's
gonna be I mean she's huge right now but
she's gonna be like an icon for a long
time yeah said it you heard it here
first
retweet yeah no I think she's like
already an icon but yeah but you can't
be an icon if you've only been around
for so long you know like there's so
many people remember to make a trainer
people are saying she got released
oh my god the funniest part of big-time
adolescence yeah was when the girl said
to Machine Gun Kelly key play Meghan
Trainor
I was I think out loud like when Lady
Gaga released Fey monster we're like oh
she's it she's gonna be a big star icon
and then she went on to beat those
things and I think doula is already in
that place of yeah she's those things
yeah but some people uh
release albums that make you think
they're gonna be everything of the sort
and then they in turn end up being
nothing of the sort
like you Meghan Trainor like literally
all about that bass like people were
like literally my future husband people
will respect the hell out of Meghan
Trainor and by the way she's still
putting on music the song she just put
out with Nicki Minaj is really so good
yeah but I'm just saying she's people
thought she was gonna be on the same
track but she's not no but like she is
she was a judge on the phone did she say
really but she's not a nobody but she's
not an icon like she's not no when I
think of pop stars people I would have
to name probably 300 pop stars to you
it's like it's like Jerry Seinfeld says
it's like music is more personal than
food oh my god what he said that he
always says comedy is more personal than
food I would agree and it literally took
me on the hundredth time of him saying
it for me to understand what he meant
it's like you know you're so many
community like something might taste
good to me that doesn't taste good to
you of course and this is something
might be funny to me that's not funny to
you ice cream and lemon people get
special Meghan Trainor song might be
good to me and it's not good to you yes
I hear what you're saying Jackie I'm not
saying the music's not good I actually
agree that it is good but you can't sit
here and look at me and say she's as a
big of an icon as do a Lipa like I'm
sure I'm talking about in terms like
drop her albums and like drop their
panties ticket sales like she's very
respected yes she's a judge on the floor
she's a very respected songwriter she's
not a nobody but I'm saying like when
her out but her music first came out we
were like oh my god these songs
everything was Bing after being her and
then she just kind of faded away and now
she's still doing stuff but she's not
everything of the sort no she's not
everything of the sort but she's
something of the sort
yeah yeah and it's not a road I didn't
like scan her but I'm speaking up for
the stands because like she actually
made a space for herself in the industry
you just you just made my point yes she
made a space for some yes I agree I just
can't believe she's a judge on the floor
like yeah there's a little weirdness on
the for ya like Charlie walk yeah and
that whole show was weird I actually
been watching The Voice a little bit
this is I didn't know what song you were
singing until I said I thought this is
boys um yeah Jonas I mean that they have
like all the musical talent in the world
and that sir and they could come up with
Nick Jonas is the new I like the voice
because it's like this
yeah Nick Jonas is the new judge and
people are loving him
I think he's doing actually a really
good job but Kelly is so good I've never
watched a Kelly Clarkson season she is
like made for this show love to see it
love to see it and John Legend is good
too and like Blake Shelton I'm a kind of
over him he does this annoying thing
where like he'll like someone but he
won't turn around till the very last
minute cuz he wants to be the only one
it's so lame mm-hmm it just turn around
give the person respect get some respect
on his name but respect is earned yeah
okay next story are you guys ready for
it to get into it because Taylor Swift
and Kim Kardashian since yesterday have
both spoken on the video situation we're
gonna read their statements then we're
gonna Duke it out even though I think
we'll probably end up in the same place
no I think after all after all this I'm
probably even more staunchly on Taylor's
side okay cool
Taylor Swift posted on Instagram instead
of answering those who are asking how I
feel about the video footage that leaked
proving that I was telling the truth
the whole time about that call you know
the one that was illegally recorded and
somebody edited and manipulated in order
to frame me and put me my family and my
fans through four years of hell swipe up
to see what really matters and then she
posted a link to the world health
organization and how we can give back
during this time of crises and so that
was that and that was classic Taylor you
know she's gonna use the moment to not
only reiterate what she has to say in
her side story but then also greater
good but then also you know make it
about something philanthropic even
though it is very much not that okay and
then Taylor Swift I'm sorry Kim
Kardashian tweeted last night many also
on her Instagram stories but the same
exact thing yes many a tweet even
tagging Taylor yeah by the way and on
Instagram - mm-hmm at Taylor Swift has
chosen to reignite an old exchange that
at this point in time feels very
self-serving given the million the
suffering millions of real victims are
facing right now okay
can I just say what's wrong with that
statement is that she didn't choose to
rig now that the video was leaked and a
lot of people could argue that the
Kardashians leaked it so therefore
you're choosing to ignite it that's all
I'll say oh I don't think the
Kardashians liked it I have no idea I
don't think that they did either no I
think the video leaked
whatever but like Taylor Swift spoke on
it as opposed to before that she was
just liking tumblr post I was kidding
like Twitter and that would have been
fine but Taylor spoke on it and I think
Kim's mentions must be flooded with this
because the fact that she's even
addressing it is so crazy but no no it's
not that crazy it's a big deal by the
way it's not crazy that she's addressing
it it's a really really big deal plus
Taylor did like mention it so of course
Kim's gonna go back and forth on it and
to be honest Kim should speak on it
because similar to how the video that
Kim posted like exposed Taylor this
leaked video really exposed Kim and
Kanye and that has been the sentiment
I've been seeing worldwide whether you
agree with it or not
oh I don't agree with it she said I
didn't feel the need to comment a few
days ago and I'm actually really
embarrassed and mortified to be doing it
my god okay I just have to strip down
Kim's response because I hate when
people say that like I know nobody cares
but if nobody actually cared then why
responding because if you're horrified
while you're trying everyone thinks that
she's been exposed so my piece planing
people comfort Kim like all the time she
doesn't respond to every little thing so
if she could have been what if you're
gonna speak on a speak on it and you're
not gonna speak on it don't say you're
mortified but then still speak on it was
one of the biggest beefs rivalries of
all time when it's [ __ ] between her
and some low-level cyber tea yet she
ignores it because she's not gonna give
that person more press but this is like
a list level beef and she's gonna speak
on it I'm just but if you're gonna speak
on it especially in 8 tweets like just
don't be like I'm I hate to even speak
on this but you are speaking on it so
just own it yeah I sometimes I hate to
speak on something but it needs to be
said Ozona she said but because she
continues to speak on it I feel I'm left
without a choice but to respond because
she's actually lying to be clear the
only issue I ever had around the
situation was that Taylor lied through
her publicist who stated that quote
Kanye never called to ask for permission
they clearly spoke so I let you all see
that nobody ever denied the word [ __ ]
was used without her permission we can
all agree there at the time when they
spoke the song had not been had not been
fully written yet but as everyone can
see in the video she manipulated the
truth of their actual conversation in
her statement when her team said she
quote declined and cautioned him about
releasing a song with such a strong
misogynistic message the lie was never
about the word [ __ ]
it was always whether there was a call
or not and the tone of the conversation
just came up to toast yesterday because
this is literally what I had said but
she was acting like a girl who hadn't
been called okay so Taylor didn't
respond to this but Taylor's
Publicis did because kim misquoted
tailor statement from the publicist so
what was the scene when but and this is
the most important part of the story and
i think we touched on this yesterday is
like what actually did taylor do or say
before the phone call was was released
to make everyone think like she was
playing the victim and the only
statement that ever came out of Taylor's
camp was to Entertainment Weekly I think
and it said Kanye West did not call for
approval but to ask Taylor to release
his single famous on her Twitter account
she declined and cautioned him about
releasing a song with such a strong
misogynistic message Taylor was never
made aware of the actual lyric I made
that [ __ ] famous wait but that's a lie
he called for both things he called for
her to post it on Twitter and he called
to run the line by her he the Twitter
thing is true she but yet but she didn't
decline she didn't decline him using a
lot yeah yeah so she acted like a girl
who hadn't been called no no but this
statement proves that she and
acknowledge that there was a call she
acted like a girl who hadn't been called
about using this line she actually
hadn't been called about being used in a
song she said that she was just actually
tweet about a song it could have been
any sooner right but this this statement
never said that there wasn't a phone
call so this was before the phone call
was ever actually released Taylor
acknowledged that there was a call yes
but that only that he didn't get her
approval on the lot on a line about her
yeah but you know something we said
yesterday that I really realized in my
sleep that I was incorrect about is that
we said the only thing that really
wasn't adding up was that Taylor came on
the Grammy stage and said there will be
people who try to take credit for your
fame but the line
I made that [ __ ] famous was the line
she didn't know about yes I agree with
that so in fact I think her Grammys
speech was justified in the sense that
if maybe she had known that he was maybe
her issue was that he called her a [ __ ]
but also that he took credit for her
fame probably more so for sure yeah okay
so now the only thing that we need
explanation is that this statement says
that she declined when both versions of
the video show that she showed that she
did both lines of Iowa she owes me sex
or we might still have sex yeah but not
the [ __ ] won no cuz that line had him
in Brittany yeah Kim also said I never
edited the footage another lie I only
posted a few clips on snapchat to make
my point and the full video that
recently
doesn't change the narrative I agree you
missed the before-and-after but what she
posted she didn't chop I have two
problems with that one she said I didn't
edit I just cut it up which is Larry the
definition of editing she had it in it
by the way like wait how so the
definition of editing is to like move
take thing take things out geez cut she
just clipped she gave us a minute of 30
minutes okay but it's just a clip no
it's literally the definition of editing
no but editing would be like cutting and
pasting when she just clipped the
pertinent information for us know the
definition of editing is preparing for
publication by correcting condensing or
otherwise modifying it she edited it she
didn't modify it
she condensed it without taking anything
out she took out really important
context oh I I disagree but okay and so
and by the way and she said it doesn't
change anything the narrative is still
the same I totally disagree I think the
narrative is it's totally changed you
get a real sense of what the
conversation was and to be honest the
conversation we saw in the snapchat and
the conversation we saw in the 30 minute
phone call were just so different like
towards the end it literally seemed like
she had been coerced for 30 minutes into
the thing and then we get what she said
at the 30th minute not literally all it
took to get her there the hesitations
and the the the visible uncomfortability
yeah I'm totally different I think that
sure of snapchat no well she wasn't
posting 30 minutes to snapchat but she
edited it's edited it's not it's
condemned she said to add Kanye's an
artist has every right to document his
musical journey in process just like she
recently did through her documentary I
agree with that I don't think they shade
Lee a film term no I think they filmed
this whole life I agree
Kanye has documented the making of all
of his albums for his personal archives
however has never released any of it for
public consumption and the call between
the two of them would have remained
private or would have gone in the trash
had she not lied and forced me to defend
him that's why the last time I speak on
this because honestly nobody cares and
like the toasters and the scene II sweat
pea cannot handle this I just can't like
I literally wake up with a pit everyday
like knowing I'm gonna have to go on
here and defend my queen Taylor when Kim
is also my queen and I love them both
and I just I can't stress that enough
and I know that we're never gonna get
like a reunion between them two I just
need everyone to stop talking about this
because to be honest they're both super
sheisty and I think they both use the
situation for what they wanted it to
nobody's right but I think Taylor was
painted out to be the villain and
everyone was just so excited to like
bon Taylor and the thing it's like I
feel like sometimes people are exposed
or technical isn't great but like the
degree to which and maybe it was also
because she totally yes like both if she
one month later had come out and like
was just back to business I got like
some birdies do this all the time and
make us forget whatever was going on
with them before but the fact that she
took a whole year off it's all we made
talk about for a year I totally crazy so
guilty I think that like her
cancellation was worse than others and
that's just because first of all there's
varying degrees of cancellations I mean
we know firsthand like our cancellation
was the biggest cancellation in the
world and now people come around to the
same thing and nobody gives a [ __ ] they
say yeah I think it's just it's it's how
cancel culture works there's an
algorithm and you don't know how it's
gonna work out but I agree I don't think
she helps her case by disappearing
because obviously it's how she felt but
the world really moved on like a month
later nobody really cared a week later
but her disappearance obviously made it
more of a question mark but at the same
time like she was just not ready because
she was not ready to move on because
people were turning on her even her own
fans like I remember literally and even
myself I had questions so I think that
it was made into a bigger deal and like
now it's like the same thing like people
really feel like this new video has
exposed to Kim and Kanye and there's
nothing happening to Kim and Kanye
they're not taking a year off like it's
just it's it's so different and it sucks
right but if Kim and Kanye after like
this video was posted when silent for a
year then we would be like oh my god I
can't believe they did that but now it's
just part of now we're just having a
conversation about it right but Kim and
Kanye are like controversy experts like
they're his Kris Jenner has a machine
like they know exactly how to navigate
his machine also know but see that's
that was the whole point I know how to
navigate the hate that was the whole
point of and everyone like secretly for
one reason or another whether they could
define whether or not why or not they
hated her they had some sort of paid for
and this video gave them a reason to so
like everyone who's ever had like a
weird feeling about Taylor Swift just
like jumped oh yeah because that every
day she's always like she's so
calculated but yeah but Kim lives her
life like she started out as like you
know a sex tape so she's always been
fighting back but for Taylor this was
the first time that like America's
Sweetheart yeah where she just had to
take the heat yeah so there are varying
levels of cancellation and I think it's
really interesting that Taylor's was the
biggest one I think partly because of
the way she handled it like that was how
she decide
to take a year off and that's totally
fine but it obviously makes it into a
bigger deal and then the whole album
that came back was really all about that
and her reputation which is you know her
artistic expression and we totally are
here for it and respect it but it makes
it into a bigger deal yeah and the album
like what's all about it's all you can
think about yeah some interesting very
interesting I was a cold situation that
just got me feeling really anxious and I
really hate it and I just want to get
under my hush blanket I just want it
down and I I need I've been using I how
she like it every single day and I'm
Jaco right here to the hush blanket
because I just hate this teeny Swifties
hate me so much they do I honestly I I
understand but we can like we can agree
to disagree and I think at the end of
the day we all agree that Kim was
talking about one thing and Taylor was
talking about another check yeah we
totally agree to disagree i think if i
could if i can speak quickly before this
ad on behalf of the Sini's fifties i
think the frustration lies and like a
lot of times you play into like the
stereotypes of taylor that are so untrue
that really get to her the most like you
see in her documentary like she's like
people have been calling me calculated
my whole life when I'm just running a
business and like if a man were to do
any of these things they would just be
like he's so great where it's me it's
like I'm a calculated Queen because like
I have I want to I want to put an image
out like everyone does that Beyonce does
everyone wants to have a certain
perception of themselves especially when
they're famous even not famous people do
it so it's like why when Taylor does it
is it the most calculated strategic she
has a plan for everything but when other
people do it they're just being famous
and have running a business so I think
sometimes you play into that and it's
frustrating I feel like Isis teeny
scripty like we're oh that's our plight
like we're always fighting against that
narrative a like Taylor's calculated and
everything she does is a move in
strategic what it's just not actually
and so if you watch a documentary like
you'll really understand that so I'm and
I feel in by the way sometimes I know
that I'm definitely like a blind Taylor
Swift fan like not everything just like
the person that you stand is does is
right and you just sometimes have to
blindly defend them and I do that with
Kim sometimes than I do the Vitello
sometimes I just think in this one like
I have to go with Taylor I would I do I
really see but I just besides the
documentary didn't make me think that
she's not calculated like maybe it did
for you but to me it made me see that
she is calculated and I respect the hell
out of it yet it did yeah but I just
hate the word calculated because that
she like she is it forward features
thoughtful and yes exactly and I respect
it I really do and she does it everyone
in the world does it but when Taylor
Swift doesn't it's different why why so
this whole situation has gamma angle
flare ups on another level and my
husband gate which is our new sponsor
there waited blankets first of all I
don't even know if we've done a read for
them yet but I am obsessed
- covered in dog hair Theo doesn't stop
doesn't stop using it and part of the
reason why I really like it is because
I've seen some ugly ugly weighted
blankets this one is so cute his mind's
eye got the blue velvet and eye blue
velvet pillows on my bed and it matches
perfectly amazing I have the blue velvet
also I am obsessed and by the way of
course it's it's ok way to blankets our
fabulous blankets they're super cute but
the weighted element it really can help
reduce stress anxiety and I really feel
like part of the thing that's so magical
about a way to blanket is that they keep
you warm
like I never realized I couldn't look
like it literally doesn't keep you warm
because it just sits on top of you but
the weighted element really keeps it
extra warm yet my favorite thing to do
is to put on my way to blanket and pick
up my Kindle and it's just like anxiety
free you know when I own world me it's
my hush blanket and my tick-tock the
quality of the blanket is substantially
better looking and better quality than
any other brand on the market they make
their products with only the best
materials and some of the benefits of
using away the blanket is you can have a
deeper sleep you can stay asleep longer
and genuine genuinely feels like a hug
and it's proven to help people who
experience anxiety and stress plus hush
blankets as a give back program where
they donate 1 in 10 adult link it's and
one in five kids blankets to charities
and shelters in need it has been a huge
part of their brand since day one they
understand that not everyone can afford
a hush blanket but they absolutely
deserve a better sleep program plus they
have 100 night guarantee you can have a
hundred nights to test out your blanket
if you don't love it send it back to up
to them for a full refund no questions
asked
if you feel like it's too light or too
heavy you can exchange sizes so they
have varying levels because a small
person would need a smaller one and a
bigger person would need a bigger one
like I didn't even realize like there's
like a sizing system which is genius -
technically the throw so that's perfect
for the edge of your bed oh yeah okay
fabulous fabulous well if anyone wants
to get a hutch blanket during these
quarantine times I feel like you might
actually really need one we have an
offer if you use code use code toast for
$50 off all weighted blankets at hush
blankets calm the discount code is toast
you can get $50 off at hush blankets
calm thank you hush for sending us
blankets and for sponsoring this episode
because I'm their fabulous sign on be a
little less anxious in a crazy [ __ ]
time crazy
okay next story love we got that like
thing out of here I just I can't I mean
it's always gonna be the thing that
breaks us I don't know it's gonna be the
thing that breaks me like no and I hate
that I have to sit here and like speak
ill on Kim because and Kanye because I
absolutely love them and they're like my
heroes I just I my soul has taken me to
the tower side and I know there are so
many toasters who feel the exact same
way like they're stuck in the middle and
they just don't know how to feel and to
be honest before this whole thing like I
never said it but I kind of live with
Kim but after the documentary and after
the video like I am just so staunchly on
Team Taylor and I just feel as though
I've been letting the Swifty's down in
the past and I refused to do it
I refuse well you know what that's
what's great about this show dynamics
dynamics and we agree on literally
everything so every once in a while
we're gonna flare up y'all
halsy and Evan Peters appear to have
broken up like who cares I mean I
literally love Halsey but she is the
absolute worst taste in men like I love
her so much I feel like I'm really
turning into I'm not there yet but I
will be a Halsey Stan I think her new
music is fabulous I love her friendship
with Taylor Swift I love her take on all
things like music industry I think she's
a really strong powerful female um but
when it comes to dating like I just I
literally think she we have opposite
tastes in man like she likes like bad
boys who are like bad and I just I want
her to have a business man beau yeah she
will absolutely never anything ever info
would be wasted on her she doesn't have
one but like now he was obviously I'm so
glad she never ever had a baby with him
it keeps obviously really bad for her
mental health her physical health like I
just think she's spoken a lot about how
it was definitely an abusive
relationship then she was with Evan
Peters who's a really dark human being
and I don't know if that's just because
he's on American Horror Story or because
he actually is dark but I'll never
forget his life-saving work and
sleepover and to me he'll always be that
kid with a skateboard yeah we should
have sign that as two as movie of the
day okay I'm so in Nancy I mean just
would you rather Hillary or a brownie so
just find guys who would also have
brownie over celery such an iconic
analogy people are saying that she's
back together with Young Blood as they
both put both posted a picture of the
same plate of food on their Instagram
yesterday maybe suggesting that they're
quarantined together um she was with him
I don't know a young blood is but he's a
very fabulous music producer whose name
is always attached to fabulous projects
yeah it is a part of um new Lady gaga
yeah and he's also always doing stuff
with five seconds
summer I feel yeah that song it's called
young blood and I don't think it has
anything to do on blood so you wanna I
mean I also we've got young I think it's
um that girl from x-factor B Miller but
she's like really weirdly famous even
though like she made it no we're on
x-factor yeah um just really quickly
any time 5 seconds of summer is brought
up on this show I do feel the need to
say if you're not streaming 5 seconds of
summer new album new music like you were
so missing out there the most fabulous
band in the world they don't care about
like you know pop culture politics
they're just in it for the music these
guys from Australia I absolutely love
them so let's go to a concert if there's
a summer and I'm really hoping it
doesn't get cancelled because like I
will actually cry yeah
I just want to say 5 seconds of summer
enough times that like someone on their
management team like knows and I must
and and like lets me come backstage to a
concert even though I did meet one of
them backstage at stagecoach and I
totally ruined it I just feel like
there's a lot of toasters in a lot of
places but like in a rock band I mean I
don't know there was a toaster at the
White House that's how the show happened
there was a toaster at the White House I
think if there's a toaster at the White
House there could be a toaster who works
in the music industry ok ok they didn't
buy no story after a lot of speculation
the 2020 Tokyo Olympics have been
postponed until 2021 the Japanese Prime
Minister confirmed oh my god wait this
changes everything so is is the next
Olympics gonna be 2025 are they going to
stay on the 20 of the four years because
that would be crazy you know and other
cities are already building and so I
think it'll just be pushed back one year
which is actually makes a lot of sense
they can still do it in Japan and the
same place that they were building yeah
and by the way I'm really hoping to get
my ass to the Olympics and now I have
one more year to become like more famous
more successful so that made me we have
a shooting shot in hell I was actually
gonna try and go to the Olympic or
coronavirus I was gonna try to go to the
Olympics this year because it's my dream
and like to go to Japan and then I
thought like that would be a perfect
time to go
or maybe the worst time to go cuz it's
like super busy but I think this is a
great decision and a lot of people were
like wondering why it hadn't been
postponed or canceled yet and I think
Japan was like holding out hope which I
totally understand and respect cuz I'm
doing the same thing about like a lot of
different things in my life including
cam toes oh my god I know I don't even
want to talk about it but for those
who've been asking like we have no plans
right now to postpone or cancel we will
make a decision
May first I think yeah we'll see where
we're at like things change every day so
much what if tomorrow there's a cure
you know yeah I heard that they're you
know clinically testing a new drugs
we'll see yeah we'll see so and it's not
like people are still buying tickets -
tickets are bought so you'll get a
refund if we cancel yeah and some people
have requested refunds and that's
totally okay so whatever yeah they first
um anyways see in twenty five twenty
nine but by the way if we do have to
move camcos it'll be moved he will not
be cancelled we'll see
there will be no they'll be like it
would still be happening we can only do
it in so many months and we might still
be quarantined in July if things are
really bad if we're but I think we can
do it latest in September let's get me
did the first one I know and like the
weather was weather was bad yeah so just
pray for us so now everyone's weddings
and stuff are moving to summer I think
everyone like literally my wedding all
spring weddings are being moved to the
fall and I already bought all my spring
wedding dresses so annoying because
they're so springy I really can't wear
them and yeah but I guess it's more in a
way for the bride no but oh yeah I just
our whole way I know but like it's
Curren biros like it's bigger than you
and I feel like all these weddings that
I have like now I have one where it's
like I have a wedding on Saturday and
wedding on Sunday in two different
states I'm gonna have to go to both cuz
they're both super important oh my god
what states New York in Dallas
[ __ ] yeah so like every weekend of the
fall is gonna be weddings that's crazy I
am I'm just like really badly waiting my
life I guess I was invited to no
weddings because I haven't had to move
any get new dresses and I'm not mad I've
said it once I I think weddings are
beautiful like please don't invite me
unless I'm super important like I just
hate going to weddings where I don't
really like know I hate going to
weddings period um and if I'm like a
bridesmaid or like really know and love
the couple then it's fun and it's like a
lot of my friends but if I'm just like a
guest like someone in Ben's family
I [ __ ] hate going to weddings like
although dressed up like weddings that I
have this year are super important it's
either I'm a bridesmaid or Zach as a
groomsman oh that's funny we'll have to
go to every single one even the ones
that are rescheduled you know I have not
one wedding you have one no Sam oh yeah
yeah that'll be fun yeah 35 yet almost a
turducken Sam things oh and uh Tina yeah
- how are you - okay great Kristin oh my
god those are like family friends though
like honestly Dana Kristin
Sam are really your friends who are my
friends - but they're your friends that
you're inviting you're gonna be there
okay fabulous
I'm so excited and one second ago I hate
weddings please don't no but see these
are people like I've known Dan Sam Dana
and Kristin forever especially Kristin
like I'm so happy for them like that is
the type of wedding I can go chances
Impa that's the only type of wedding I
want to be at but if it's like someone's
cousin or like oh this guy one of Ben's
old friends married some random girl
like I really have to go no you don't
I watched um James Charles YouTube video
when I couldn't sleep on my muscle
relaxer last night he did a tutorial
with Charlie Gemelli oh he did her
makeup while they were just like talking
about take talk and she's so sweet and
so shy and they literally had a whole
conversation about like fan fans like
being so disrespectful and some of the
stories Charlie was saying we're crazy
like she's all even famous for like six
months and literally she was like out to
dinner with her friend and her friend's
mom and they were sitting and eating and
this woman came over and she was like my
daughter like loves you so much like
she's at the other table like would you
mind coming and Charlie was like yeah
can I finish eating and then like I'll
come over and we talked or whatever and
literally the mom made Charlie cry she
was like really this is so disappointing
I'm telling my daughter to unfollow you
like learning made Charlie cry in a
restaurant and it was just so
interesting to hear how these people
like talk about fan interactions and
James Charles did everything in his
power to make the entire video about him
like literally Charlie would say like
this happens music oh my god yeah like
that happens me too like at this thing
two years ago the key was being so
annoying but he did fabulous makeup on
her like a beanie eye you can see it
they kind of look like no but they were
making fun of his tick-tock hands which
reminded me of you oh that's me also all
these take stalkers like it's Addison
and Quarantine with david dobrik okay so
they have been together a lot otherwise
why are they hate you they're in drafts
like they just film them a while like
she was hanging out with them a lot last
week or they just live super close to
each other in the quarantine oh my back
oh my god you guys oh my god you don't
the table just fell over almost cuz
really you're next time Oh watch watch
the replay it's coming oh my god my back
you guys it's so hard to sneeze with a
broken back okay we're gonna recap the
trust movie of the day we'll assign the
new one and get to anything else that we
watched and that segment is brought to
you by third love third love does bras
differently they believe that every
woman deserves to feel comfortable and
confident every day but the right kind
of support they help her do this their
bras are designed to fit you not the
other way around
they're designed with measurements from
millions of women their bra styles are
made to fit your life they have over 80
bra sizes but we know the only one that
matters is yours and the only one that
really matters is mine because until I
started using 3rd lovin before I took
their quiz online I had absolutely no
idea what kind of bra size I was
supposed to be wearing and I was running
the wrong bra for like the last 5 years
best part of 3rd love is that they
believe in giving back they donate their
gently used bras to women in need so
basically you go online to third love
calm you take their fit finder quiz
where you answer a few simple questions
to find your perfect fit in 60 seconds
over 15 million women have taken the
quiz to date it's super fun and they ask
really intricate questions like what
type of breast shape do you have I have
a breast shape and I'm wearing your
third love bra right now it's the
t-shirt bra I absolutely love it I have
it in white on nude and black they've
the perfect fit promise so every
customer has 60 days to get the bra wear
it wash it put it to the test if you
don't love it you will return it and
third level wash it and donate it to a
woman in need their team of expert fit
stylists are dedicated to helping you
find your perfect fit and your perfect
size returns and exchanges are free and
easy third love knows there's a perfect
bra for everyone so right now they were
offering our listeners 15% off your
first order go 2/3 love.com slash
morning toast now to find your perfect
fitting bra and get 15% off your first
purchase
that's third love.com slash morning
toast for 15% off today Thank You third
love for changing my boobies cyanine
getcha titties at so our movie of the
day yesterday was Mad Money a very
underrated film a comedy starring Diane
Keaton Queen Latifah and Katie Holmes
and I absolutely loved it I think
anything Diane Keaton does like she's
actually never done a bad movie okay
even like a bit like this is like a bad
movie it was good yeah no she's great
it's funny because the way I think of
her in my head she's like you know old
rich white lady like by the lobby
whenever she's in a movie low-key she's
like so frantic yeah but he's like so
crazy and like physical and like manic
she's an amazing actress no she is but
like she just has this like manic energy
about her and it's like I always kind of
associate her with Meryl Streep but like
she's not that no she's like you know
the the anxious Meryl Streep yeah but
she I don't know if she's just like so
physical the Ted Danson of it all was so
weird the movie was honestly so good it
was the perfect kind of movie I guess I
don't think I had seen it before I mean
and even though like the ending was a
little lackluster yeah because like this
whole plan that she had like it was just
did it come to fruition
like and I just don't believe that like
three people really could have
outsmarted this Federal Reserve actually
makes a lot of sense they just throw the
money in the trash yeah I know but likes
stealing from the feds it's like a
federal crime like they wouldn't just
let that go because there's no proof you
know that there's no proof it was a
genius
crying crime I thought the weirdest cast
was Katie Holmes I don't know anything
about Katie Holmes like to me she's the
weirdest actress I could just fell off
the face of the earth and I heard in my
DMS and I went to IMDB to do a little
fact-checking that she we were talking
about her yesterday because she was in
two of the batman's and then they she
didn't return and they replace her with
Maggie Gyllenhaal I had heard that she
left to do mad money and I looked on
IMDB and the timeline was Batman Batman
mad money there's absolutely no way so I
just heard that I don't know if it's
true there's absolutely no way yes she's
weird to me because I don't know
anything about her other than like Tom
Cruise obviously but like her
personality in the movie was just like
not what I expected from Katie Holmes I
just feel like she would take herself so
serious no I know but then it made me
seem like maybe made me think maybe
she's an amazing actress because I've
never thought of her in that free spirit
kind of way no or maybe she's just a
free spirit like I don't maybe that's
what she's actually like yeah um Queen
Latifah's role was giving me a Pitt
because she was the only one with like a
true moral compass and she was the one
who had like the most at stake and they
were just really taking advantage of her
because she was the one who actually
like was I don't know actually they were
all integral to the actual crime but
like she was the actual one I don't
actually Katie Holmes was actual one
liked Anna money but she just heard the
most at stake and yeah they like got her
a deal at the end and then it ended up
being fine but she was the only one like
who was really had a good head on her
shoulders she was like this is where you
get greedy like they should have stopped
when they were at that dinner yeah and
she kept saying that like this is a bit
slippery and the premise of American
greed yes exactly but you get what you
want at that dinner accepting it all did
work out in the end so maybe not the did
she have this plan long months of if she
was siphoning the money into that
restaurant I just really wanted Diane
Keaton like to win like I wanted her to
go to the barbecue with that nasty
neighbor like I just wanted what is her
neighbors husband from oh my god I don't
know hold on he's a glass of like
Million Man factor he's from something
and
like the dad is it it takes to know
what's his thing okay Christopher
McDonald how about I'm about to get it
I think he's so cute he's from happy
gilmore oh yeah that's not what I'm like
from that's not what's like seared into
my brain okay um not like all these
movies we've never gonna say hold on I'm
gonna find what it is he's so handsome
I've never heard of any of these movies
I feel like he's from a TV show no it's
probably happy gilmore that did it for
me
really that's not it for me yeah he's
like the mean guy who's good at golf I
love that movie happy gilmore yeah I
guess maybe it's happy gilmore
that's just like not what I was
expecting okay now I'm at like the
twilight zone when it comes to assigning
our next movie I'm like afraid because
we mentioned we wanted to do sleepover
and I love that movie I just don't want
to watch it and realize how dumb it is
like I know it's forever ingrained in my
mind is the best movie of all time and
like I'm happy with that
I totally agree so the movie that I
chose that I haven't seen that like it
was on my list of things that I maybe
wanted to watch is the laundromat I'm
napping you were gonna say that I don't
know I just feel like it's an underrated
movie here's the description hey I saw
the trailer and I just I didn't hear
anything about it which makes me think
it was terrible yeah Meryl Streep isn't
it but it's when a widow gets swindled
out of her insurance money her search
for answers leads to too cunning lawyers
in Panama who hide cash for the
super-rich it's Meryl Streep Gary Oldman
and Antonio Banderas directed by Steven
Soderbergh I was gonna suggest a
superstar from last week which we never
got to do so maybe we just leave it up
to the toasters we'll do a vote in our
poll like what kind of vibe I don't know
we haven't really decided like what vibe
toast movie of the day is trying to
emulate I feel like it's all over the
place you know so Christopher McDonald
is in the House Bunny I think he's on
the ball yes he holds the meeting at the
end like the Greek life meet oh yeah
honestly I think that's what I have him
in my brain I see it I see it so funny
um okay so we'll put it to a poll
whatever the toasters mom we'll do it on
our Instagram story so make sure you're
following us at the morning toast we are
so close to g1 jerk' and I feel like
once we have to intro K like we are a
real news empire we're at 192 so like if
everyone watching could just like follow
us maybe make a fake Instagram account I
would really appreciate it yeah then
we'd hit it in no time
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning to us if you haven't checked
out our new episode of
morning toast this morning we had an
extra episode with dr. deborah birx who
was a doctor for the White House Task
Force against coronavirus she was
amazing we got her via Skype and it's
fabulous it's available on our youtube
channel but it is also gonna be
available at the end of this podcast
episode thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast of London
Morning Show where we go live Monday
through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
on YouTube so if you're watching us on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we are
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so that's Spotify
iTunes stitcher Public Radio I Heart
Radio cash box all the places where ever
you listen to podcast find us the
morning to us and maybe leave a five
star view but a beautiful stunning and
smart we are we love you guys so much
stay stay thank you to all of our nurses
our doctors our toasters in the wild who
are out here saving lives we love you
guys so much and we will see you
tomorrow